Shh top of the morning to you laddies
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to how well do I know
jacksepticeye I honestly have no idea I
just did the video where I was doing me
quizzes and in the recommended section
it was like Jackson by little boy I'm
not used to calling him jacksepticeye
I'm just gonna call him Jack or Shawn or
I don't know I'm about to pick his name
I don't know do I even know his name
I don't know so anyway I saw the quizzes
in the suggested feed and I went to
myself and I was like well do I really
know him I haven't looked up any
supplementary information I haven't gone
to his wiki to try to find out anything
about this and kind of want to see how
this goes cuz I have no idea so anyway
what's jacksepticeye's real name Felix
Arvid who's super or Jack space sceptic
space i what if he legally changed his
name to Jack space sceptic space I Oh
mister I Oh call me Jack I'm pretty sure
pretty sure even though I still I call
him Jack all the time even when I'm like
seeing him in person I call him Jack and
I'm trying to break the habit but it's
so engrained in my brain to call him
Jack Sean
his name is Sean where is he from
Ireland
that's not Irish oh yeah London everyone
did will earlier Ireland I've done sound
right Adie pronounced okay Hayden what
the [ __ ] was that Aiden Aiden
jeezum Asian we try see about me yeah I
don't know who to believe
I don't know to believe here I've got no
guidance this is a bunch of [ __ ] ok
Perlas pronounce a agen didn't know that
one Ireland is he in a relationship and
if so with who uh yeah Beauty pie now he
is SEPs
septic pie will live on god that is the
worst ship named Marc septic pie is that
the triple ship name not the lovely we
who gave him a shout-out to boost his
subscribers I don't know I don't know no
he just earned his subs by himself with
no shoutout well I mean this is the this
is the conundrum of a shout out because
a lot of people get shoutouts but it's
all about the person's ability to retain
the viewers that really is their own
work so even if he got subs from a doing
videos with PewDiePie or be doing videos
with me it's still him keeping people on
board and that's all him that's all the
skill that he does so in my opinion here
in the subs by himself he may have had a
shout out but in my mind that's probably
irrelevant was the ship name between
markiplier and jacksepticeye there isn't
any it doesn't exist
there's no effect it doesn't exist how
many subscribers does he have all of
October 1st 2016 he's just hit 13
million so at that point he probably at
twelve point at 49 million there twelve
point three five how old is he ah he's a
sweet baby boy he's a sweet baby boy of
26 what a sweet baby boy okay [ __ ] you
guy you piece of [ __ ] I'm not gonna look
it up not gonna look it up a meenie
miney moe catch a tiger by the toe if it
goes a little bit doesn't hurt in how
many episodes of happy wheels is he at
as of this date probably pretty damn
high but not quite 100 yet hope you
enjoyed all the quizzes bye bye boy boy
boy what a day [ __ ] god damn it I got a
C which is average a passing grade I
don't even know what I did wrong
probably the birthday and the last
question I don't know what I did oh yeah
I said there wasn't any well [ __ ]
oh well what can I do start off what is
Jack's real laugh [ __ ] you was seeing
Shaun Shaun with her when's the Shawn
got an accent on it without Jack a boy
Fischbach that doesn't make it a goddamn
sense
Shaun Jack Shaun Jack mcLaughlin you
know wait you know Shaun Jack
[ __ ] [ __ ] Shane Shane septic I you know
how that works
Shane septic yeah [ __ ] it oh nice you
know you know you know jacksepticeye
wait slightly green Shack
you know jacksepticeye here you know you
know what I okay anyway Shawn William
mcLaughlin what was Jack's first video
gmod with markiplier his channel didn't
start until that video there was nothing
before that I'm willing to bet that
because one of these things is not like
the other it might have been a Solid
Snake impression I don't know though let
me go to his channel this is the only
one I'm gonna cheat on because if it is
a solid snake impression I want to see
it an okay we're gonna die we're gonna
we're diving here we're diving into the
old we're diving in oh oh my god it is
oh no oh no oh yeah oh hell yeah hell
yeah
has changed it's longer about nations
ideologies it's in the series of proxy
battles for this reason I feel bad for
electric I feel really bad for laughing
but my god that is hilarious
I've never seen that I mean how does
this only have 600,000 views how does it
only have 600,000 that did have millions
of views my god it was amazing I mean no
it wasn't but it was pretty good you
know I love that so much and then that's
what I love I love going back and being
like unnerve [ __ ] seen any of this
[ __ ] my god okay alright I'm not gonna
just make this whole video watching his
old videos because I would he be
embarrassing them but I'm sure he'd hate
before it but it's okay cuz I love that
the suit
I never knew that I've never gone back
and looked at these you don't know jack
as the review series what you play in
Jack oh my god
everyone tweeted jackets say you should
bring back you don't know jack so like I
said this is not gonna be about that but
I had to know if that was a solid snake
impression and that was a solid solid
snake impression I like that very much
so what's Jack's age at pride 26 how
many subscribers October by about that
I'll give him the benefit of the doubt
what nationality is a Korean German
American where shall escape from what
does Jack's longest series today
probably happy with no he probably has
more reading your comments than happy
wheels I don't know if vlogs could be
considered a series but I'm pretty sure
he has more reading your comments and
happy wheels the Shaq's favorite game
definitely not happy wheels I believe a
Shadow of the Colossus but I'm not our
presenter about that one who gave Jack's
channel a shout-out Lord V the one and
only Lord minion 777 on a dark and
stormy day about three years ago
descended from the heavens and looked
upon Jack straight in his eyes and said
Jack well [ __ ] that's a bad waiting
pressure jack no Jack no Jack that's
better Jack your content is good in my
mind I shall bless you with the shoutout
sound like Wade if you do a side-by-side
of me and Wade you couldn't tell the
difference probably the wonderful Wade
gave him a shout-out where did the quote
detained come from papers please
Britt into quote I will bring you the
wrath of a thousand badger buttholes
come from um I'm assuming it's live
aerial but maybe not what is Jack's
outro us long as [ __ ] man is fruit each
episode if you liked it
kick kick kick kick kick kick light
button hmm maybe I could steal that I
like kick punch is overrated you kick it
in the face that's assuming the like
button is down
the ground and just huddled in a heap
and kicking it repeatedly in the face
that's how much you should commit to the
like button I feel like a punch in the
like button then it's like a kick in the
dislike book take a minutes just like
button that's what I really take him
down and [ __ ] changed people started
kicking in the dislike button spies by
for [ __ ] by just what if that was how
every youtuber ended the videos but by
[ __ ]
I like aa bunch alright fine hey I
didn't do too terribly that wasn't the
worst I bet has got his birthday wrong
but I'm pretty sure I was right about
Wade giving him a shout-out pretty sure
oh [ __ ] hell Sean
Wilfred mcdougal Oh Sean good old Sean
Wilfred mcdougal who the [ __ ] is Sean
Wilfred apparently this apparently this
guy right here this handsome gentleman
right here this is Sean Wilfred mcdougal
what did he graduate college not an
engineering degree Hotel Management for
his channel saw Sagan president yes how
did people hear about Jack when he was
about two thousand subs oh I forgot
about that
Oh Felix had like uh yet like I have
this thing he used to do he had like a
like like a shout out to ah youtubers
that seemed cool like thing he did it
along he doesn't do it anymore but he he
used to do this thing
what's that it I don't think so I I'd
like in my mind in my mind I'd like to
think it wouldn't have mattered either
way people just started showing up and
talking and spreading the word that's
what in my heart of heart like and no
one can deny he's earned every sub that
he's had I would say the same thing to
him and I probably have a million times
but this guy like he didn't he didn't
get popular because of anyone it maybe
he won off PewDiePie shout out
competition but he's earned everything
who crafted the person although you hope
great song as of 9 to Jack is ranked and
popular well I don't know this is it's
like a question to do they include like
the music channel or the gaming channel
or the all channel on YouTube 4970
7:49 how many subscribers in September
oh oh that one ah maybe I don't know I
know I'm pretty good hey I know that guy
I'm Steve Oh Steve I know if that guy is
that guy back there
that guy looked familiar I'd recognize
the back of that head at any time what a
good guy that me that's not me is it
that's not me
hairs - sure not as floofy is that me I
don't know he's wearing red
I do wear a lot of red that's bit is
that me I'm doing it yeah let's judge by
the back of the head [ __ ] me oh I
knew it was me
oh I know that broad shoulders anywhere
so anyway that is the end of do I know
jacksepticeye and the answer is whoo
yeah little kind of like a Steve amount
like a Steve level of knowledge like I
have a Steven knowledge anyway that is
the end of this and I want to reiterate
that all this is in good love to Jack a
boy right there he's a great guy if that
wasn't evident of course he's great he's
[ __ ] Jack septagon all loved him I
hope he's not offended by this in any
way I'm sure he's not I'm sure he's just
offended by the fact that I got some
things wrong but no no no no no about
that because I'll delete it this video
is never gonna be uploaded so thank you
everybody for somehow getting to this
imaginary video that never made it to
the Internet let me know what you
thought down the comments below if
there's anybody else that I should
probably know let me know that as well
so thanks again and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]